man is with us Ben's in Connecticut hey
Ben what's up in your world man well I
have a little bit of a relational
problem I'm hoping you and dr. D can
help me with
okay bring it on so I just entered into
my first relationship in two years and I
am punching way out of my league here
that's a good sign
even I can both identify so continue
fantastic I've been on baby step two for
the past two years the first year was
gizelle intense the last year I had some
real bad news knocked my emotional you
know emotional wind out of me so I was
acting like a donkey but this girl that
I'm dating now debt free cash flow to
master's degree and has her three to six
months and I'm afraid she's gonna
realize I'm a donkey I've got 70 grand
left in debt and I just don't know how
to deal with it
so why are you sabotaging this thing
before it even gets off the ground man
it's not like I'm not you I've expressed
her I of the debt and she's fine with it
she's the cheerleader for me that's just
my problem is feeling to me like I'm
inadequate yeah so you've got a picture
yourself with a cinder block that just
says I don't have value and you're
carrying it around looking for the next
wonderful person to hand that to why are
you doing that well the reason I've been
single for two years I had a marriage of
fell apart the wife had a boyfriend
behind my back for six months there you
go and so somebody handed you a brick
that said you're not worth anything and
you're still carrying something that
somebody handed you and so the work
you've got to do is to put that sucker
down put the cinder block on the ground
and leave it there take the lessons you
learn from the last marriage whatever
you brought to it good and bad take the
pain that somebody put in your back
pocket acknowledge it own it and then
put that brick down and if you've
stumbled into you walked into you
created a scenario where you attracted
somebody who's extraordinary honor her
love her and
value yourself and man run wide open
there is one way to guarantee you're
never gonna get hurt again
and that's to never love again
pain is the price of love it comes with
it and in my life it's always been worth
it so let me ask you something
does the amount of debt that you have
make you a donkey or what you're doing
about it
it was what I was doing about it which
was nothing yeah and then I looked at
the Harley for sale so are you because
your ex was a liar of a trailer and did
and broke her promises
how does that make you a donkey it
doesn't okay I don't think so I was a
leading question by the way and hey let
me give you this one if you got hit by a
car and you got up and stumbled and
tripped over a curb would it be fair for
me to say you're clumsy yeah okay so you
got run over by a truck you made some
stupid decisions with money it's not
fair for me to call you a donkey you've
recognized it you got it
you picked yourself up you dusted
yourself off
go get it man if you get this framed
right in your head and you start working
to get out of debt I think it makes you
a thoroughbred because you're coming
back from catastrophe if you sit on the
corner and sit on the curb and suck your
thumb and the rest of your life this is
your identity yeah I'll go with donkey
because you're you're adopting the
position of victim then but you're not
all it is is you're just in the hole and
she's like shiny right now you get to
know her a little better you're gonna
find out you probably got a wart or two
but um cuz there she comes from a family
DM so yeah well that's okay right that's
okay that's okay so do my kids
and and yet that my kids when they were
dating we're not you know the person
that was marrying into our family we had
to explain to him it was not a perfect
family looks really shiny there's a lot
of bright lights around us and we talk a
lot but but far from perfect and so we
had to warn the potential suitors coming
into our lives this is a very difficult
family hey Ben can I ask you this
question do you do you not trust this is
something I've run across with folks who
have been cheated on do you not trust
this future person to not care for you
or have you lost trust in yourself lost
trusting myself I trust her more than
anything there you go okay so I want you
to value yourself as a trustworthy guy
yeah okay you didn't do anything wrong
you're scratching back from getting
kicked in the teeth and you know I don't
I don't think I'm talking to a donkey
and if you've listened this show for
very long I would have told you you know
that and a Ben you're looking at two
guys who've been knocked down before
yeah and usually David I want speak for
you but the times I've been knocked down
it's because I've punched my own self in
the face and so you're getting back up
man you've got yes you know and I'll say
it may be a good thing to do some you
know that depend on what stage this
relationships in it's good to sit down a
good marriage counselor no remarriage
thing always and just say we always talk
we pretty much demanded it of our grown
kids to go get good pre-marriage
counseling always where they discover
you know you know this is what's wrong
with your family of origin and you're
gonna bring that in and here's the
process problems right and this is
what's wrong with this former marriage
and you're gonna bring that in and oh by
the way these everyday millionaires over
here aren't quite as shiny is by God
they look like on the first date or
second day or even fourth date you get
in there you're gonna find out that you
know they got every family's got
something that's right and some of them
put the fun in dysfunction you know and
so on
you know you get in there figure it out
and but get somebody to kind of coach
you guys through this and that levels
the emotional playing field because
right now it feels like it's not just
money that's not level it feels like the
this characters not level and in pains
not level yeah and you start both
speaking the same language yeah and then
you can walk this out together
good one you've been or you don't good
for you been very good very good smart
guy